hello everyone and welcome to the finals
of the chesable masters knockout phase
it's pragananda versus dingleroon and
this is game three in game one as you've
seen ding defeated pragananda with the
black pieces then in game two uh prague
struck back with the black pieces also
it was a
very interesting game but in an equal
end game uh ding
missed one move and prague was able to
take advantage of that um of that end
game uh so the uh result is now equal
and now this is game three again prague
with white ding with black let's see
what happens will we see a repetition of
game one uh or will something new be
played so d4 we have knight to f6 by
ding c for e6 and now not knights the c3
like in game one probably goes for
knight to f3 sort of the anti-names of
variation because in game one uh being
uh declined
the nimzo uh sounds a bit odd when you
say declined the name so like it's uh
like the nimzo is the greatest opening
of all times uh but you know everyone is
playing it nowadays and he went for the
queen's gambit declined instead but here
uh he just uh repeats with d5 we have
knight to c3 and now pawn to c6 sorry
about that and we entered the semislav
defense we have bishop to g5 by prague
uh knight b37 e3 and now queen to a5 we
go into the cambridge springs variation
or rather the cambridge springs defense
of the queens can be declined and this
is not a very very long theoretical
struggle so see captures on d5 knight
captures on d5 and now queen to d2
adding more defense to the knight on c3
we have bishop to b4 adding a third
attacker and rook to c1 nicely defending
we have h6 bishop to h4 and now b6
preparing to uh play bishop to a6 you
want to trade off this bishop for white
slide square bishop you know the white
slight square bishop always gets the d3
and from there it's it's a monster so it
makes sense to trade it off bishop to d3
and bishop to a6 and now you can't just
move the bishop back to b1 to keep it as
you will be unable to castle due to this
bishop being on this diagonal so here we
have castles uh being also castles and
ponte e4 now prague forces some traits
here on the c3 square knight captures b
captures and the bishop to a3 attacking
the rook and here uh rook to b1 is a bit
more common but prague goes to rook to
d1
uh we have rook f the e8 and then now
comes rook to f1 rook f2 e1 and this is
now a new move uh so already as of move
16 we have a completely new game so a
very uh standard setup probably with the
strong center rooks nicely placed on the
d and the e uh eel e file uh bishop on
h4 ready to come to g3 if needed uh so
everything is nicely placed and ding has
uh well he has a lot of activity and the
possibility of a queen side expansion if
pragma allows it so here are dean trades
bishop captures queen captures and now
rook ate the c8 saying that he is ready
to charge at the center with c5 we have
h3 and now interestingly uh ding does
not go c5 he goes b5 and here he says i
will go c5 and then i might play c4 like
in game one as prague really had
problems dealing with those uh
with the b and c pawn that soon became a
pass pawn so rook to e2 preparing to
double up on the e file now queen a4
remaneuvering with tempo uh rook d to e1
and now bishop backed to f8
uh and here prague needs to decide
how to go about this position whether he
wants to keep it solid with something
like rook to b1 or maybe e5 uh just you
know keeping the tension rook to c1
waiting for ding to figure out what to
do or to go aggressive with g4 this is
what uh prague plays and this uh well
allows ning to play a very principled
move uh if your opponent expands on the
king side you will strike in the center
so he plays c5 challenges the center
d5 by prague this will give prague a
pass pawn at some point and now c4 so
here ding pretty much with a similar
setup like in like in game one uh the
pawn will come to b4 and then uh a pass
pawn will be created so queen back to d2
pawn to b4 going for this right away
there's no time to waste and now uh d
captures an e6 this is how uh prague
plays it and uh being just captures on
e6 we have knight to d4 challenging the
rook and the rook to b6 so not a lot uh
not a lot to do here for uh for prague
uh we have rook to d1 uh sorry queen to
d1 not rook to d1 queen to d1 offering a
queen trade and the ding accepts we have
captures captures and now b captures on
c3 so ding created a pass pawn and how
will uh
well how will you tackle this rook the
c2 going after the the double c pawn
knights the c5 now here uh uh ding is
going after the e4 pawn and the idea is
if the pawn is defended he wants to go
rook to b2 this is how he wants to play
it and after rook captures knight a4
attacks the rook rook moves we put the
pawn to c3 to the c2 and so on uh but uh
prague decides to give up the e4 pawn he
goes for the c3 pawn right away knight
captures an e4 and now rookie three
attacking the knight knight back to f6
and now knight to e2 so you now have to
create some sort of a barrier at uh
uh stop this c pawn in its tracks but
it's not going to be easy bishop to c5
attacking the rook on e3 rookie 5 attack
as the bishop but okay the bishop is
defended so just rook to b2
attacking tonight but also gaining
control over the over the c2 square as
your pawn now wants to start marching
forward knight to c3 and the bishop to
b4 so everything is ready uh we have
rook to c1 defending the knight and now
knight to d7 attacks the rook rook to e4
we have knight to b6 and now comes a4
but now rook to b3 with a double attack
on the knight here knights to a2 and now
we have bishop to d2 attacking the rook
but also the bishop just nicely controls
the c3 square so rook c2 we have c3 and
now rook to d4 but here that dean just
played rook to b2 and he was in this
position on move 39 that uh pragananda
resigned the game and uh third victory
in a row with the black pieces uh uh the
second one for ding uh in uh well just
uh just a crazy crazy game so it seems
that uh
black pieces are the one uh doing all
the damage and stirring all the trouble
uh what will happen in game four will
probably be able to bounce back and get
a win with the black pieces on demand
and force tie breaks or will ding just
uh you know make an easy draw and and
win the game for those of you who don't
know even if the first match is over
there will be a second match tomorrow
it's not like who wins the days the is
the winner of the event no there will be
a second match tomorrow uh so yeah here
you resign because there is nothing for
you to do your rook is attacked you
can't move it anywhere and if you trade
then okay there's no stopping um
uh upon the b1 you can grab the bishop
but then b1 queen comes with check and
it's game over so here prague resigned
and very interestingly ding makes use of
the bnc pawn he just pushed them
seemingly effortlessly and prague was
just unable to do anything about this so
uh
very very nicely done biting that's not
not an easy thing to do
so yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it very nicely done by ding i
would like to wish a very happy birthday
to salvatore kano and i would like to
thank mark manor uh boston.cat uh first
elden lord and nagarjuna pongotti for
your contribution to my channel thank
you a lot i really appreciate it
as usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you for watching and i
will see you soon most likely with the
final game of the match uh
as soon as it it it finishes uh so thank
you all i will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day